- [Voiceover] So, we have
a reading passage here.
It says this passage is adapted
from Edith Wharton, Ethan Frome,
originally published in 1911.
Mattie Silver is Ethan's
household employee.
So, Mattie Silver, that
must be a character
in this passage right over here.
And before we even start to
read this passage together
it's probably worthwhile to stress
that we should get pumped
about reading this passage
because if we're interested in it
we will comprehend it better.
But even more importantly we're about
to spend a few minutes of
our life on this passage
and so if we're gonna spend a few minutes
of our life on something
we might as well enjoy it.
So, let's do that.
All right.
Mattie Silver had lived under
Ethan's roof for a year,
and from early morning
till they met at supper
he had frequent chances of seeing her,
but no moments in her company were
comparable to those when, her arm in his,
and her light step flying to keep
time with his long stride,
they walked back through
the night to the farm.
So, it sounds like he likes her.
He had taken to the
girl from the first day,
when he had driven over
to the Flats to meet her,
and she had smiled and
waved to him from the train,
crying out, "You must be Ethan!"
as she jumped down with her bundles,
while he reflected,
looking her slight person.
"She don't look much on housework,
"but she ain't a fretter, anyhow."
But it was not only,
and I don't know quite
know what fretter means.
I'd have to think about that
but it seems like on the context.
But it was not only that the coming to his
house of a bit of hopeful young life
was like the lighting of
a fire on a cold hearth.
The girl was more than the bright
serviceable creature
that he had thought her.
She had an eye to see and an ear to hear.
He could show her things
and tell her things,
and taste the bliss of feeling
that all he imparted
left long reverberations
and echoes he could wake at will.
So, he felt not only was she
kind of this fun, bright,
spirit that coming to the life.
He felt that she, that
there was a connection
that he could make with her.
That she had an eye to
see and an ear to hear.
That she could, that he
could show her things,
and then awaken an
appreciation for things.
Let's just keep reading.
This is interesting.
It was during their night
walks back to the farm
that he felt most intensely the
sweetness of this communion.
He had always been more sensitive
than the people about him to
the appeal of natural beauty.
His unfinished studies had
given form to this sensibility
and even in his unhappiest,
in his unhappiest moments field
and sky spoke to him with a
deep and powerful persuasion.
But hitherto the emotion had remained
in him as a silence ache,
veiling with sadness the
beauty that evoked it.
He did not even know whether anyone else
in the world felt as he did.
No, I actually feel that
when I look at nature.
But anyway, that's, this isn't about me.
As he did or whether he was a
sole victim of this mournful privilege.
Then he learned that one other spirit
had trembled with the
same touch of wonder.
That at his side, at his side,
living under his roof and eating his bread
was a creature to whom he could say,
"That's Orion down yonder.
"The big fellow to the
right is Aldebaran,"
I'm not quite sure how to pronounce this.
Ahl-deh-berr-een. Aldebaran.
"And the bunch of little ones,
like bees swarming, they're the Pleiades."
Or whom he could hold entranced
before a ledge of granite thrusting up
through the fern while be unrolled
the huge panorama of the ice age,
and the long dim stretches
of succeeding time.
The fast that admiration for his learning
mingled with Mattie's wonder at what
he taught was not the
least part of his pleasure.
And there were other sensations,
less definable but more exquisite,
which drew them together
with a shock of silent joy.
The cold red of sunset
behind winter hills,
the flight of cloud-flocks
over slopes of golden stubble,
or the intensely blue shadows
of hemlocks on sunlit snow.
When she said to him once,
"It looks just as if it was painted!"
it seems to Ethan that the art
of definition could go no farther,
and that words had at last been found
to utter his secret soul.
So, he clearly likes this girl.
She's, she works for him so
it's a bit of an awkward relationship,
but he likes her not just
because she has this,
I guess it sounds like positive energy,
but he loves being able to teach her,
and show appreciation of nature,
and it seems like some of
the science that he knows
about the stars and
geology and whatever else.
And so, he kind of likes being this
not only companion, this
co-appreciator of nature,
but he also likes being her teacher
and feels that it's awakening things
in appreciation for
science and nature in her.
As he stood in the darkness outside
the church these memories,
all right, so everything we just
read so far these were memories.
These memories came back with
the poignancy of vanished things.
All right, so we just read all this stuff
but he is thinking about them as he stood
in the darkness outside of the church
as if they're gone, that
they're not there anymore,
that these things are no longer there.
There's a poignancy of vanished things.
Watching Mattie whirl down the floor
from hand to hand, whirl down
the floor from hand to hand.
I wonder what she's doing.
He, ah, maybe she's cleaning
or she's doing something else.
I'm not sure but let's keep reading.
Watching Mattie whirl down the floor
from hand to hand he wondered how he
could ever have thought that
his dull talk interested her.
So, now he's saying before he thought
that he was really charming her by telling
her about geology and about the stars
but now he's saying he wondered
how we could ever have thought
that his dull talk interested her.
So, now he, it seems like he thinks
that she actually wasn't as
interested as he thought.
To him, who ever.
To him, who was never
gay but in her presence,
her gaiety seems plain
proiof of indfference.
All right, so he was never
really that jovial of a guy
but when he was around
her by seeing her gaiety,
her kind of happiness, seemed
plain proof of indifference.
So, why is that?
The face she lifted to her dancers.
All right, so he's around
some dancers now, I guess.
The face she lifted to her dancers
was the same which, when she saw him,
always looked like a window
that has caught the sunset.
Oh, okay, I see it.
He thought that she was this kind of,
this positivity, this
connection that he felt,
was something that was
only between him and her
but now he's feeling, "Well,
"she does that with everybody."
He even noticed two or
three gestures which,
in his fatuity, so when he
was infatuated with her,
he had thought she kept for him,
a way of throwing her
head when she was amused,
as if to taste her laugh
before she let it out,
and a trick of sinking her lid slowly
when anything charmed or moved her.
All right, so before he
thought that they had
had this very unique connection
but now in hindsight he's like,
"Oh, she wasn't interested in me at all.
"She does that, she does
that with everyone."
So, let's now read the questions.